[Music]
navi have been on the brink of greatness
for years and they've never been closer
than they were in 2020. you're iem
cannabiza 2020 champions it's normal
but it seemed like the team was still
missing something that one crucial
ingredient that would finally push them
over the edge there was a lot of people
who were questioning how navi can be so
good one week and then you know the next
things look like they're falling apart
so when bit joined the lineup a lot of
people weren't sure if this rookie could
take navi to the top
but as it turned out
it was exactly what na'vi needed
oh but he's been fumbling with his knees
and they both lined up for him two more
head shots for the tally and bit puts g2
down in the dumps move over scream
there's a new headshot machine bits the
man he's legit you've never seen a
rookie like him
[Music]
at just 18 years old bit has already
picked up some of csgo's biggest titles
he's an intel grand slam champion a
blast premiere finalist and iem masters
winner and oh yeah he's already won a
major bit ten seconds by the plan oh no
that's falling apart that's gonna be
nico there's no time he just has to
watch that clock kick down this is it
i'm taking the major
well he's not the youngest player to win
a major that honor still goes to care by
bit came pretty damn close fit
18 years old
the newest member to navi you now hold
the major trophy you've got a big smile
on your face is this just the beginning
of greatness for you
yes so who is bit and how did an
inexperienced teenager take na'vi to the
top
bit learned about cs by watching his
older brother play 1.6 on the family
computer when he was a kid growing up in
ukraine
once global offensive was released bit
quickly made the switch and he even
bought his very first skin a safari mesh
for the ak-47 outside of video games bit
was involved in amateur combat sports
for about 8 years
[Music]
as time went on cs go was slowly
becoming bitt's number one priority
[Music]
so when he heard about an open call for
young players to take part in na'vi's
esports boot camp a then 16 year old bit
threw his hat into the ring
at the boot camp bit skill impressed the
coaches and at the end of the selection
process he was signed to navi junior's
newly formed roster
chaser
as a part of the junior squad bit spent
about a year building up his reputation
and improving his skills
and while a lot of people thought bit
was good he was actually so good that he
was starting to piss off some of the
people he was playing with
despite how well he was doing though it
didn't seem likely that bit would
graduate from navi jr any time soon that
is until fate intervened
during an esl pro league match against
heroic na'vi found themselves down a man
as electronic was unable to connect to
the server so they brought in bit as a
substitute so ladies and gentlemen of
substitution has been called in
electronic unable to return to the
server and therefore navi fielded a new
one it's bit standing in for this game
as if being thrown into a pro league
match with only minutes to prepare
wasn't stressful enough until that
moment bit had never even practiced with
the main roster but this was his one
shot to impress some of the best players
in the world see what he's got he's
dropped the molotov again flashes to
come out lots of pressure will be
applied here
has he seen enough he's seen a few i
think that's gonna be a call for
assistance to come in they're on the way
but he's got to deal with someone
himself that's first that's bomb not bad
tesla for a second that's the kill good
enough work to buy some time rotations
are here yeah he's done more than he
could ask for him then flash load them
his frags slow them his smoke slows them
bit has delivered na'vi brought in bit
as a sixth man a few months later and
many people were skeptical about the
choice navi have brought in a new player
and as was also brought up he doesn't
have tier one experience and i think as
tim mentioned he played vertice pro
didn't do well in that one game versus
vertice pro but once again bit stepped
up to the challenge there is a chance at
this mid wrap around that is bit
with a little bit of utility
his fried grenade will miss the mark his
smoke
he's amazing
oh
welcome to the big weeks 3v3 versus
astralis and he gets two of the kills
boomich gonna find that last one navi
winning pistol bit still responsible for
this flank and s tag is there
two in the round already
it's gonna be needed to deliver us a
little bit more taps them out and now
he's on for the ace
oh
400
000
on the line for this retake that is the
difference
and it's all on glaive low hp for three
navi they've got it navi have done it
your blast global finals grand champs
what do you make of this young man how
do you view him i will just tell him
don't think that it's final because it's
another game for him and
we knew we knew that he gonna show up i
believe in him for the whole tournament
because he's a special guy and
he just he's just a great guy and he's
great addition for our team bit was
fitting into the lineup beautifully but
there was trouble on the horizon valve
cracked down on six-man rosters
penalizing teams that subbed players in
and out on specific maps it seemed like
a bit was an easy cut and that he'd find
himself back on na'vi jr's roster but at
the same time flamie na'vi's long time
rifler was struggling with inconsistent
performances see when flamie was good he
was really good player coming up close
simple needs a flick but he's oh flamey
just swings and saves his eyes dropping
the ball and flamey does it all but when
he wasn't the team really felt the
impact of his shortcomings simple just
dies to it straight up bird to a crisp
flaming with the miss shots jump shot by
the back ten
how so when navi were forced to pick
between the two players they chose bit
and sent flamey to na'vi junior instead
we wanted to do something we got six
main roster and pete is the young guy
he's unexperienced but he still uh
have a lot of potential and he's he was
a much better option
for us
than flamie if you want to perform
better that's
easy so almost a year after his fateful
performance against heroic bit was now
officially a core member of one of the
best teams in the world
and the pressure was on he had some
mistakes but yeah every time we tell him
to not forget everything we discussed
before map and just focus more
communication between us and
more on his aim but despite all that
pressure bit didn't crack and na'vi just
kept winning lots of pressure on him and
he's gonna be jumped on okay spins the
deagle upgrade very short-lived and the
fan mask is good for two make it three
oh boomers here now in turn on two this
one's done yeah he's gonna get the ace
if he's not careful hades finished off
and that's all five
wow bit
newest arrival to navi but
you could be fooled he looks very
comfortable in that jersey
just as the flash comes in from the
opposing team do instant headshots and
he gets all four for himself
he just makes it look so so easy for hp
wants to check ct simple's not going for
it but
versus simple and it's good for the navi
boys only zai wu can possibly save them
only zai who can deny the intel grand
slam navi a couple of bullets is all it
takes and there it is
their domination is secured
but bit was about to be tested like
never before
the stockholm major was the first one cs
go had had in years and it was navi's
best ever chance to beat their
years-long major curse i'll tell you
what though if you're bit and you're
going into your first event to play in
front of a crowd and an audience on a
stage and it's the major
that's got to be that's got to be
worrying that's that's not a good
prospect like think about it just one
bad game one bad game at the wrong
moment in the quarter finals and they
get knocked out that sucks but bit
didn't just hold it together he
dominated
interesting i thought perhaps they'd
stick the plant that fit would actually
take that fight but instead simply
wanted to bait his own battle instead
goes down it is all under bit and
refresh
damn and that is a lovely shot from bit
it is nine to nine that is domain and
he's right up and ready ready to mow him
down in a small bit three
knocks off heads there's nothing left
for the suitor vitality's plans foiled
by the rookie and the superstar for good
measure the dream if they had a smoke
and they do
jax surely can drop it oh but he's been
fumbling with his knees and they both
line up for him two more headshots for
the tally and bit puts g2 down in the
dumps 10 seconds by the plan oh no he's
falling apart that's going to be neat go
there's no time he just has to watch
that clock kick down
this is it
zombie
while all eyes were on simple bit turned
out to be a crucial part of navi's
historic victory there are players who
have spent years playing cs go and are
still waiting for their big moment bit
has only played two land tournaments in
his life and he's already won a grand
slam and a major for most players that
would be more than enough i don't know
how far he could take this but if he
continues on this trajectory
it could be something we haven't seen
before which is crazy to say in the era
of simple zaiwu niko right so i'm
excited to see
bits career progression but navi isn't
done yet which means bit isn't either
sharks flash in front of bit
beaks into it and there it is
copenhagen looking like vitality's
coffin
but bits right here he stops it sprays
away the defuse comes
may be vitality's coffin but it's navi's
castle and for as long as young players
like bit are out there cs go has a truly
bright future
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock